لم اعرف ما هو ولاكونن خائفا في حين راى
بيل فلاورز ذ 93 عاما كلبه ليبرتي يقف
بالقرب من ساق بشريه في فناء منزله خشي
الكهل الامريكي اخبار الشرطه استيقظت في
صباح احد الايام حوالي الساعه الثامنه
والنصف كنت ذاهبا لاطعام الكلاب وهذا
الكلب هنا كان يقف قرب الساق تفحصت
والتقطها ونظرت الى اصابع القدم ولم تلحق
بها اي ضرر من الركبه الى اسفل
القدم ويقول فلاورز ان لون القدم كان
رمادي وبدا انها قطعت على مسافه اربع
بوصات من الارداف الا ان فلاورز قرر
التكتم على الامر ودفن الساق التي جلبها
كلبه كان لدي شعور مضحك اعتقدت انه علي
استدعاء الشرطه وقلت لنفسي لا يحتاج الامر
سوى لدفنها ودفنتها في كيس من البلاستيك
كنت خائفا من الاتصال بهم فانا في ال3 من
العمر ولا اريد التورط في شيء لم افعله
ووضعت المباحث الجنائيه طوقا يحمل جهاز
تحديد مواقع على امل ان يؤدي بهم الى باقي
الجسم حيث اسفر التفتيش عن العثور على
المزيد من البقايا البشريه منها جمجمه
وقفص صدري في هذه الغابه المجاوره لمنزل
الكهل ولم يتضح بعد اذا ما كانت تعود لرجل
ام
امراه